we are here in the city of kiev the
ukrainian capital and after five weeks
of war we are seeing signs of life
beginning
to return to some semblance of normalcy
this high-end restaurant just reopened
here alcohol sales are allowed today
starting this morning for the first time
since the war started alcohol was banned
following the russian invasion and we
have seen people here beginning to stalk
the shelves the restaurant owner here
says that so far they've been about a
third full so certainly not back to
normal but really remarkable when you
consider that just this five weeks ago
this city was in vladimir putin's
crosshairs many expected that keeve
would fall to russia and indeed the
fighting does continue the ukrainian
forces have been pushing back northwest
of the city successfully reclaiming some
villages as well as the city of urpin
the pentagon says that around 20 percent
of russian soldiers who had been set up
just outside of kiev are now
moving believed to be repositioning
presumably helping the war effort in the
east so there is still fighting there is
still bombing here and you can hear it
but it is in the distance and i think
you know people here are saying they've
actually kind of gotten used to hearing
the explosions in the distance most of
those bombs have not landed here in the
city center and people here really are
hoping and praying that the worst may be
behind them jeff semple global news
keeve